MINHAZ KAZI: Welcome
to "DataVis DevTalk."
I'm your host, Minhaz
Kazi, Developer Advocate
for Data Studio.
In this video, we'll talk
about the connector manifest
and why it is important to have
the right information there.
Let's get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Your connector's manifest
is a special JSON file
in your Apps Script project
that specifies certain metadata
about your connector.
Apps Script needs some
of this information
to run the script successfully.
Data Studio also needs
certain information
from the manifest to display
and execute the connector.
You can find out more
about Apps Script manifests
in general in the link below.
Apps Script automatically
creates and updates
the project manifest as
you create your connector
and make changes in
the Apps Script editor.
However, there are
a few properties
that you'll need to update
manually for your connector.
First is the Data
Studio property.
All information
about your connector
will be added under
this property.
Some of this information
is mandatory.
Your connector's name is
limited to 28 characters.
You'll need to provide
the name of the developer
or the organization, as well as
the URL for the organization.
You should have a logo or
icon for your connector
that should be 40
pixels by 40 pixels.
That add-on URL should be a link
to a page that is preferably
hosted on your
domain and explains
what your connector
does and how to use it.
This is the link
users will go to when
they click on the Learn More
button on your connector card.
The support URL should link to a
support page for the connector.
Users should be able
to report issues
with the connector at this link.
You'll also need to provide a
description for your connector.
This will be visible in the
connector configuration page.
Links in this description
will be clickable.
It is always a good
idea to provide
all information or
instructions necessary to have
a basic understanding
of the connector
and how to use it
in the description.
This mandatory information
is required for Data Studio
to render the connector
interface on different screens.
This information
also helps the user
to know more about
your connector
and explore on their own.
Then we have some certain
optional properties
under the Data Studio property.
These aren't required
if you're building
a connector for a limited use.
However, if you plan to
publish your connector,
you must include this optional
information in the manifest.
This information
helps to showcase
the connector in
the gallery, and let
the users quickly search
for connectors and filter
based on certain criteria.
The short description is
limited to 114 characters.
If your connector is published,
this short description
will be visible in the gallery
card for your connector.
Use this to briefly describe
what your connector does.
Users will view this
short description
when they browse through the
connectors in the gallery.
You'll need to provide
links to your privacy policy
and terms of service, list
authentication type, and fee
type for your connector.
If you want to provide a
template for your users,
you can list it in the manifest.
The template will provide
a seamless experience
for your users since they will
start with the template instead
of a blank dashboard when
they use your connector.
We will have a
separate video focusing
on the template experience.
One important entry in the
manifest is the sources.
Your connector might connect
to one or more sources.
For example, if you create
a Google Fit connector,
your source for data
would be Google Fit.
To add the source's
property, you first
must ensure that the
source information exists
in our source registry
on the Data Studio
open-source repository.
If your source does
not exist there,
you can add it yourself by
sending us a pull request.
Sources act as metadata
when users search
for a specific connector.
More information about
this can be found
in the link in the description.
There are two additional
properties at root level
that you will need
to be aware of.
If you're using the Apps Script
URL fetch app call to fetch
data from HTTP endpoints, you
should list all the endpoints
under the URL fetch
whitelist property.
This is mandatory when you're
publishing your connector.
You will not be able to
make calls to endpoints
outside of this list.
So be careful to list
all applicable endpoints,
including the ones
required for authorization.
The second property
is OAuth scopes.
Apps Script
automatically determines
what scopes a script needs by
scanning its code for function
calls that require them.
For most scripts, this is
sufficient and saves you time.
However, for advanced
use cases, like when
you're using a service
account to access data,
you might need to explicitly
define your scopes.
That covers the basics for
your connector manifest.
As we add more features to
Data Studio and community
connectors, more
options might be
available in the
manifest in the future.
Make sure to check
the manifest reference
link below when you're
developing your own connector.
You can always go to
our developer site
at
developers.google.com/datastudio
for more information.
If you liked this video,
stay tuned on the GCP channel
for more Data Studio content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]